exploding cars death defying Falls and
Bayonet stabbings it's all in a day's
work for Hollywood stunt artists at
least when things go right these scenes
didn't go right Jeremy Fitzgerald has
performed stunts in hundreds of films
and TV shows over the course of his
career creating an impressive show real
along the way while his biggest gig
might have been doubling for Liam
Hemsworth in The Hunger Games Mocking J
part two it was on a movie involving
Chris Hemsworth that Fitzgerald ended up
in serious Danger 2012's The Avengers
the experienced some man narrowly
escaped getting decapitated after he got
tripped up during a 30t fall from a
building top Fitzgerald told TMZ how he
was supposed to get hit by an arrow
presumably fired by Hawkeye and then
free four from a ledge on the way down
his foot got caught and he slammed his
head against the building's brick wall
narrowly missing a jagged drain pipe in
the end he escaped with his head but was
missing a chunk of his scalp he didn't
let that stop him from climbing back up
there for more takes however a Marvel
spokesperson said in reply to TMZ's
report Jeremy was fine he slid briefly
along the side of the building he got
right back up and did several more takes
Australian stuntman Scott mlan was
doubling for Ed Helms in The Hangover
Part Two when he suffered a critical
head injury during a car chase forcing
Hospital staff to put him in a medically
induced coma the accident took place
during the filming of the scene in which
Stu Phil Allan and Mr Chow have been
chased by Russian gangsters after
stealing their monkey They SW sve
through traffic as Stu hangs out the
back passenger window narrowly missing a
truck as it comes around the corner in
front of them the drivers involved got
their marks wrong and mcan's head was
hit by the truck according to a Daily
Mail report mlan was feared dead by his
colleagues after the impact and while he
ultimately escaped with his life his
lawyers claim he suffered permanent
brain injuries his partner rayen Chapman
who is also a stun performer said there
was so much damage he was a mess he used
to look after me now it's my turn to
look after him for a change I'm thrilled
cuz this time last year I I was barely
able to move Chloe Grace morrettes
already had 20 credits to her name when
she won the part to foul mouth
11-year-old assassin hit girl in 2010's
Kickass none of morette's previous roles
have been anything near as physically
demanding as a hit girl gig so she put
herself through months of intense
training and stunt work to get herself
prepared for the part the stunt
coordinators were impressed with how
well she adapted and learned the ropes
though they were remissed to let her do
the more dangerous scenes despite her
willingness looking back she's probably
glad when asked about the worst thing
her double went through while making the
2013 sequel kickass 2 morett said a
stunt rig led to a serious onset injury
explaining she cracked her head open
they used a hydraulic system and they
did it too much and it just pulled her
an inch too far and she cracked her head
on a bar using fake weapons and battle
scenes it's a lot safer than using real
ones though sometimes I can ruin an
otherwise perfect shot that was exactly
what David a was trying to avoid in his
gritty 2014 World War II flick Fury Brad
Pit Stars a sergeant Don Waddy ker
alongside an ensemble casts including
Logan lurman shy Le buff John Bernthal
and Mike compia AA put the cast through
an intensive boot camp and had them
partake in heavy sparring as a unique
method of bonding before the shoot took
place in England which led to a few fled
tempers ver while the film's violence
was all staged there was one moment that
wasn't a 35-year-old stuntman was
stabbed at the bayonet though the 9-in
blade luckily went straight through his
shoulder he was airlifted to Oxford's
John Radcliffe Hospital a spokeswoman
confirmed there has been an accident
between two professional stuntmen which
happened in a rehears action sequence it
was an accident it is obviously very
unfortunate the spokesman added that the
man in question was laughing and talking
as he was loaded into the helicopter the
2015 remake of Point Break may have been
torn apart by critics but it does
contain some of the most audacious
stunts ever attempted talking about the
film's death defying wing suit scene
bass jumper Jeb kis told Men's Journal
the danger is off the chart like just
impossible to even comprehend it's
probably the most dangerous stunt that
has ever been filmed it wasn't base
jumping that led to the worst injury of
the shoot however it was a killer surf
of the coast of Tahiti Luke braci stun
double Lori toer is an experienced big
wave surfer who's used to being wiped
out in the swell though he took a bad ha
to all filming scenes as Utah he took to
Instagram to describe his injuries
saying I got my myself a broken jaw some
stitches in my lip and eyelid Whiplash
to my neck and back and a couple small
puncture wounds that went through my
neck and into the back of my mouth that
apparently just missed an artery every
Mission Impossible feature has at least
one stunt sequence that seems to put Tom
Cruiser's life in danger and in dead
reckoning Cruz rides a motorcycle off a
cliff and parachutes away as the bike
plunges into Oblivion like all of the
stuns in the mission impossible films
the motorcycle gag was meticulously
planned with Crews going through
hundreds of hours of skydiving and jump
training this is far in a way the most
dangerous thing we've ever attempted and
as Cruz told Entertainment Tonight
Canada all the preparation came in handy
when the stunts didn't go exactly as
hoped Cruz was testing the jump from a
helicopter when the stunts went wrong at
the worst possible time right after he
opened his parachute he told ET Canada
you can see when I opened I was in the
wrong position and the parachute turned
into the side of the mountain had the
parachute pulled him into the mountain
the impact might have been fatal as
Bruce Willis stun double for nearly a
decade Larry rip and Kroger faced
elaborate stun set pieces on a regular
basis one however got the better of him
in 2007 while working on a night shoot
drawing filming for Live Free or Die
Hard rip and Kroger descended a ladder
on a fire escape in downtown Los Angeles
and either lost his footing or missed a
handhold as he told the Los Angeles
Times he felt head first fre stories and
though he was able to break his fall he
suffered serious injuries he recalled I
had compound fractures of both wrists
smashed the right side of my face
fractured my skull on the back of my
head couple of broken ribs and a
punctured lung his injuries required a
series of surgeries including the
insurent of titanium plates in his face
and wrists they were funded in part with
a grant by the Taurus World stunt Awards
Foundation rip and Kroger not only
recovered but also returned to work on
numerous films including Guardians of
the Galaxy Volume 2 and the tomorrow War
the 1992 movie wind a drama about the
1987 America's Cup yat races is probably
best remembered for a gruesome accident
that occurred during filming directed by
Carol Ballard and produced by Francis
Ford Copa wind spared no expense to
depict the excitement and Breakneck
Thrills of competitive sailing including
location shooting in Utah and Western
Australia the accident took place in the
waters of the southwestern coast of the
latter location in March 1991 the
sequence involved multiple 12m yachts
and Chase boats which are smaller boats
used by yacht owners and Crews for
additional transportation and storage
two of the Yachts collided with with a
stationary Chase booat sending stuntman
Trevor Helia and stunt coordinator
Christopher Anderson overboard Helia
suffered chest and abdominal trauma
while Anderson fractured multiple bones
and erupted an archery in his right leg
that later acquired partial amputation
busted me up the fair bit broke my
pelvis and arm and and uh I lost my leg
through lack of blood flow despite this
traumatic setback Anders siners
continued to work as a stump performer
and coordinator as well as an actor and
second unit director enough words have
been written about the disasters on
water well to fill the remains of the
Exxon valdies but we won't cover them
all here oh thank God briefly though
Stars Gene triple horn and Tina major
Reno were thrown from their sailboat and
required Rescue by divers while star and
producer Kevin kustner was strapped 40
ft in the air to a sailboat Mast as an
ocean storm blew in leaving him
unreachable and in danger for a half
hour often excluded from the Litany of
mishaps on Water World a St performer
Norman Howell's brush with death how
served its CER stun double and put
himself in danger for multiple scenes
like the one that saw the marina thrown
off a mast into the sea drawing a deep
sea dive sequence how will surface too
quickly and experience an embolism an
air bubble that escapes from the lungs
and enters blood vessels which can have
lethal consequences he was flown to a
hospital in Honolulu where he recovered
after spending time in a decompression
chamber World War One combat pilot Frank
tman parlayed his love and talent for
flying into a career as a stunned Pilot
Flying super supervisor and supplier of
vintage and historic airplanes for films
and television among his credits as a
stunt flyer was the great Waldo pepper a
1975 action drama with Robert Redford as
a World War I vet turned stump pilot
torman crashed a stump plane three times
during the making of the film not
surprising given it she a number of
complicated aerial stunts two of the
crashes were planned and he walked away
from them and scathed but the third
which occurred during a routine Landing
wasn't planned and sent toan into the
side of a hill he suffered two cracked
vertebrae a broken rib and a lacerated
scalp that required 58 stitches 2 weeks
later torman was back to work and
overseeing flying sequences for
television while also participating in
air shows every stum performer has had
their share of anecdotes about injuries
and Jord well filming but Bobby Holland
hunon seems to have more than his share
of behind the scenes horror stories
hunon has served a stunt double for some
of Hollywood's biggest Leading Men
including Chris Evans Tom Cruz and Ryan
Reynolds and for years he's dou board
for Chris Hemsworth we know each other
he's a friend from work Hansen detailed
to daily male Australia a Lany of the
gruesome wear and tear his body endured
or making the Thor films Mission
Impossible Fallout and Green Lantern
tanton ruptured multiple spino discs
while making Green Lantern and Thor
Ragnarok which left him with a
neurological condition called drop foot
or foot drop syndrome which causes
paralysis and certain foot muscles that
makes it difficult to lift or move the
front of the foot handon furthest said
I've also snapped my groin clean off the
bone and blew my shoulder out and
drawing Mission Impossible I popped my
rib out on set it's fair to say that
I've had my fair share of injuries talk
about an understatement stum performer
Joe Watts suffered what he later
described as lifechanging injuries after
falling more than 20 ft while rehearsing
a stunt for F9 the fast Saga in 2019 the
stun required was to be thrown From A
Balcony by Vin Diesel's double but a
safety wire malfunctioned causing WS to
plummet to the sound SES concrete flaws
his injuries which included a skull
fracture and brain trauma left him in a
coma for 5 days what later had to
undergo extensive therapy to treat
cognitive and physical problems caused
by his fall it is dangerous I mean stunt
man I've seen some bad news today yeah
that's awful it is awful what sued ff9
pictures limited the film's production
company and a subsidiary of universal
pictures for more than 1.2 million the
company accepted the blame for the
accident in
2023 the Roberts Z MEA is Romancing the
Stone stuntmen Vince dedc Jr and Terry
Leonard doubled for stars Michael
Douglas and Kathleen Turner for a scene
in which their Jeep is swept down a
river and over a 70t waterfall a
retaining cable that was supposed to
catch the Jeep and allow both performers
to LEAP free of the car and into the
water failed to do its job sending both
men and the vehicle into the Impact Zone
a raging whpo that would absorb the Jeep
but most likely spelled instant death
for the stun man Leonard in an interview
with Sports Illustrated and while it was
happening knew I was dying that this was
the end of my life thankfully lenon was
able to not only Break Free of the well
poool but also get out of the water
thanks for a group of fishermen before
he directed Smokey and the Bandit won an
honorary Oscar in 2013 and inspired the
character of Cliff booth in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood how nidm was a feeler
stun man in films and television nidm
was an innovator who introduced their
bags to break stunt men's Falls he took
his fair share of hits as well he told
the crowd at the 2013 Academy Awards
that he had broken 56 bones over the
course of his stunt career recounting
some of his most dangerous stunts for
stunts unlimited the stunt organization
he co-founded in 1970 NM singled out a
car rollover for the 1974 movie McHugh
with John Wayne for the gag he and stunt
coordinator Ronnie Rondell built a
cannon loaded with a 3-ft telephone pole
and an explosive charge and attached it
to the car beneath the driver's seat
when the charge was fired the pole would
shoot down and launch the car into a
roll finding that one one charge would
only lift the car a few inches NM and
the crew loaded four charges into the
cannon and Needum took off the resulting
blast sent the car flying into the air
before it landed on its roof nidum awoke
in the hospital to find he had six
broken ribs a punctured lung a broken
back and three missing teeth British
stun man Rocky Taylor began his career
in 1962 with Dr No and has continued to
perform stunts as recently as Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part one along
the way he lent his expertise to
numerous films including doubling for
sha connory in Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade unfortunately Taylor also
suffered a horrific injury in 1985 while
leaping from a burning building on the
set of the movie Death Wish 3 the stunt
required Taylor to LEAP out of the
window of a 17t tall building or Flames
raged around him a miscalculation caused
an explosion that not only set Taylor a
blaze but also sent him plummeting to
the pavement below he was hospitalized
with a broken back and pelvis and burns
to both his face and hands but recovered
and returned to stunt work in 2011 he
recreated the stunts that almost killed
him by leaping from a flaming platform
in London this time he walked away from
the gag why did he want to he told the
daily mail it was something I had to do
and I'm glad to have finally done it
again and got it out to my system a busy
stunt and fight coordinator Andi Chang
began his career as a member of Jackie
Chan's legendary stunt team Chang serves
as both a stuntman and an onscreen
combatant in films like rush hour and
its sequel the latter film gave Chan the
opportunity to repay Chang for his
service by Saving his life during a
stunt sequence that went Ary one of the
film's fight sequences required Chang
and another St man to fall off a moving
boat but only one of them emerged from
the water Chang was trapped under the
boat I hit my hand I hit my hand I hit
my head I try to grab something I cannot
grab anything because so snippy as his
air began to run out Chang felt a hand
Yang him out of the water it was Chan
himself but reached under the boat to
rescue his team member Chang told ABC
News I felt like a god grabbed me and
pulled me out of the water a moment
later I would have been dead he gave me
a second life when veterans stunt
performers get together what do they
talk about if the mirror 2021
conversation with longtime British
stuntmen Greg Powell and Jim dull is any
indication the conversation turns to the
movies they made and the injuries they
incurred while working on them Powell
and dor both began their careers in the
late 1960s and early '70s and over the
past 5 decades worked on some of the
movie industry's biggest titles
including multiple entries in the James
Bond Star Wars and Harry Potter
franchises they've both taken their
lumps over the course of their careers
but only once did dor come close to
death while filming Superman in 1978
dalor was supposed to LEAP from a
trampoline and fall into another stump
performer it didn't work out as he
explained I didn't get quite far enough
when my head hit the ground at his feet
I fractured three vertebrae in my neck
it was a serious injury but it didn't
keep him down dowal has either performed
or coordinated stunts in over 200 films
and even returned for Superman 2 in a
small onscreen role veteran stum
performer Tony angelotti's credits
include The Amazing Spider-Man and
repeat engagements as one of Johnny de
stunt doubles on three of the parts of
the Caribbean films the Disney
Productions required angelotti to pull
off some astonishing stunts but one step
piece in Dead Man's Chest not only ended
his stunt career but also nearly ended
his life in the scene Jack Sparrow Falls
while wrapped in a rope which unravels
and holds him aoft by one leg the yo-yo
St required a descender a wire rig that
controls performance or equipment as
they rise or fall vertically for the
stun angelotti would plummet 80 ft and
spin five times while the descender
operator maintained control of his fall
however one time The Brak wasn't on the
speed of his Spin and descend resulted
in severe injuries to angelotti's pelvis
including internal bleeding from his
femoral artery he required two surgeries
and spent a year recovery while also
contending with PTSD from the accident
angelotti suit Disney prod producer
Jerry brookheimer and the company's
safety coordination team but lost he
later returned for the third Pirates
movie and worked as a stunned
coordinator and trainer the 200 2008
James Bond film Quantum of Solace
experienced its share of production
problems from script issues due to the
2008 wga strike to complaints by
politicians at filming locations in
Chile and Bolivia these were soon
superceeded by a trio of accidents that
occurred during filming in Italy the
worst of these accidents sent two stum
performers to the to the hospital and
left one in critical condition after an
Aston Martin Employee crashed a DBS
model seen in the film while driving it
to a publicity shoot in April 2008 two
stum performers were injured near Lake
Garda in Northern Italy when their car
collided with another vehicle before
crashing into a war the driver suffered
a fractured Cranium as a result of the
accident and was airlifted to a nearby
hospital where he was listed in serious
but stable condition a second stman came
away with only minor injuries both St
men had also been involved in another
accident one week prior to the lake
Garder incident that ended with one of
the performers receiving 15 stitches
Daniel Craig told GQ at the time that
the driver was recovering from the
accident saying he was in a very bad way
we had a helicopter standing by with
paramedics because that's the way it
works every time you do a sequence like
that and they literally saved his life
Bob Miner rolled more than his share of
cars over the course of his 5 decade
career as a stunt performer and actor
I've done stunts from fighting to
driving
Miner began in action films in the 1970s
and has taken a share of injuries over
the years but the car roll over in blu's
Brothers 2000 almost cost him his life
during the St miners suffered a frontal
lobe injury that impacted his short-term
memory months of recovery in the
hospital included learning to read and
write again fortunately Miner not only
recovered those skills but also returned
to both stuns and acting in films like
National Treasure as he told the blog
just my show with the love of God and my
friends was able to beat the odds on
that accident and I made it while many
Hollywood action Styles would prefer
audiences never see them in an awkward
moment martial arts Legend Jackie Chan
has been showcasing mistakes and
accidents that occurred while making
films for decades more many of these
outakes which run during the end credit
chov Chan's sense of humor others
highlight the dangers of many of its St
sequences he told the Sunday Mirror I
use outakes at the end of the film to
show fans that I get hurt to show them
that this isn't a cartoon out takes have
shown Cham breaking numerous bones and
suffering countless injuries inuries
however Chan's worst injury and the one
that brought him closest to death
occurred during the making of 1986's
armor of God the stor required Chan to
LEAP from a ledge on the branch of a
tree but he wasn't satisfied with the
first take so he jumped again and this
time the branch broke Chan fell almost
20 ft to the ground where his head
struck a rock and drove a skull fragment
into his brain the injury left him with
a permanent hole in his skull covered
with plastic with which he often
horrifies interviewers oh my God yes yes
yes yes yes if there was a hall of fame
for the actors who wore monster suits in
movies and there really should be one
Japanese actor haruo Nakajima would be a
star attraction from 1954 to 1972
Nakajima destroyed Tokyo and other
Japanese cities as the suitmation actor
for Godzilla Rodan the lavel form of
Mothra and many other kaiju for too
company's iconic fantasy science fiction
films portraying the monsters required
more than just stomping on elaborate
miniature sets the original Godzilla
costume J weighed more than 200 lb and
reached internal temperatures of 140°
while subsequent suits were lighter they
all offered Nakajima limited visibility
and offered little protection from
explosives or flooding during scenes in
toho's water tank Nima took his lumps as
Godzilla but faced death while playing
another famous monster in an interview
for sci-fi Japan Nakajima recalled being
lifted by wires to the rafters of too
set or playing the flying monster at
Rodan suddenly the wheel pulley raising
one of the wires broke causing the Rodan
suit to go into a spin and pled 20 ft to
the studio floor Nakajima record but I
fell into the pool on the set which was
full of water that saved my life winged
suits are definitely
hard a decorated fighter pilot during
World War I dig Grace's abilities caught
the eye of silent movie Western hero Tom
Mix who asked him to crash a plane into
the side of a bar For an upcoming film
Grace accomplished it without a scratch
and went on to become something of an
expert in the artart of crashing planes
on film one assignment nearly cuss him
his life Paramount's Wings which became
the first film to win a Best Picture
Oscar tapped Grace to create several
spectacular crashes for its story of
combat pilots in World War I one
elaborate setup required him to fly his
plane into the ground at a high speed
but upon impact the restraining straps
broke and flung Grace into the
instrument panel the accident left four
of his vertebrae crushed and required a
17 we stay in the hospital actually dick
was lucky to get out of it alive
as it is he'll be in the hospital for at
least a couple of months Grace not only
recovered but also became a published
author and even served as a combat pilot
at the age of 46 in World War
II